[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul AKA he who spoils and
it's time to get into our kangsta
Paradise with Loki season
[Music]
2 things are heating up in a Jonathan
Major's way and we're finally starting
to learn more about the big bad's
backstory throughout this video we're
going to be breaking down season 2
episode 3 And discussing all the Easter
eggs hidden detail and things you missed
heavy spoilers ahead and if you enjoy
the video please hit the thumbs up and
don't forget to subscribe for breakdowns
like this every day without the way huge
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into the latest episode of Loki time
is
every now as always we begin with the
Marvel Studios logo however you've
probably noticed there's a major
difference to the music
here
played out on an old timely piano this
instantly puts us in the mood for where
we're going to be heading that is
Chicago in the year 1868 on the sacred
timeline Here We join raona Ren Slayer
who from her perspective has just
stepped through the doorway at the end
of season 1 now this is a big changer
from how Kang was in the comics with the
Victor timely Persona even being changed
slightly too in those Nathaniel Richards
was born during the 31st century and he
basically lived in a piece F Utopia
finding it more boring than a heavy
spoilers video he decided to travel back
in time and Conquer Earth using the
technology from his Civilization now
during one of his many many defeats Kang
ended up going back in time to the 1st
of January 1901 founding the town of
timely Wisconsin he then became the
mayor and built a corporate Empire up
around himself creating timely
Industries this allowed him to integrate
into all forms of technology including
the automotive field however he also
started dabbling in Rob Robotics and
even built life model decoys that would
carry out tasks while he was away these
aged as well and timely was able to come
back and pretend to be Victor's son so
he could continue operating now if
you're a fan of the old school comics
and you'll probably know that the
original Human Torch was an Android and
timely was reconed into having a hand in
making this he also provided security
down the line for Avengers Tower which
could be what the king building in the
void had links to anyway what we get
here is a vast departure with timely
being a child of the 18 100s I know that
this is definitely played across like
one of his many origin stories but
technically this is the sacred timeline
so it's where either he who remains is
from or one of his main variants
potentially he who remains may have even
killed Victor and then taken over his
timeline while cutting down the others
we've never heard any version of K
confirm if their name is Nathaniel yet
and potentially when we do that will be
the true version of Kang now if this
isn't he who remains then why would he
choose to live in a timeline that he
doesn't belong to well it's something
that we saw cap do with Peggy if you
follow how the Russo's interpret end
game and this may have been a timeline
where the best decisions were made man
could have ended up in the morius
universe but instead he's out here
looking after Mobius now what we see
playing out is the literal definition of
the bootstrap Paradox with is showing us
the theory behind it in live action when
talking about time travel you often get
lots of different situations where you
could go over how certain things would
work if they were actually real for
example the the most famous ones the
grandfather Paradox in which you'd be
unable to go back in time and kill your
granddad because if you did then you'd
never be born therefore you couldn't go
back in time and kill him hence why it's
classed as being a paradox now when it
comes to the bootstrap Paradox that lays
out the groundwork by imagining a
scientist who one day gets a knock at
the door upon opening it up he finds a
buck there which clearly lines out how
to build a time machine the scientist
then uses this and travels back in time
knocks on his own door and then leaves
him up the book also huge shout outs to
the channel smart by Design I've used
this animation on countless breakdowns
um when I was talking about dark and
stuff and I've never giving them a shout
out because I'm a piece of so
apologies for that but yeah this always
comes in useful now there are theories
that the book would Decay and fall apart
over time as that's the thing that's
remaining consistent I've never really
found out why it's classed as a paradox
though and I thought that it might be
down to that however it could also be a
chicken and egg situation where it can't
happen first if we view time minear
fashion in order for it to operate time
has to be cyclical and exist all at once
as part of a big block now what we
witnessing with he who remains is him
very much creating his own origins in
his death at the end of time once Loki
and Sylvia arrive he then sends raona
back to give himself the TVA manual this
then allows him to walk the path where
he'd become he who remains who then
tells ravona to go and give himself the
book it's a bit of a head F but it's the
bootstrap Paradox playing out of a
thousand of years and creating a sort of
oroboro cycle playing into the themes of
the Season Kang's new Origins somewhat
based on this as well with it being
updated and only myself left to conquer
that saw young Nathaniel going back in
time and then bumping into his older
self who then started to train him
killing Nathaniel's first love this ped
the two in a war across time in which
Nathaniel battle versions of K
throughout most of history now in the
end he became a bitter old man that
journeyed back to the spot where he
first met k here he encountered a
younger version of himself and we
watched this the cycle and play it out
again you also have this sort of being
based around the Lesser known time
travel novel by hdls which was called
The Chronic Argonaut released in 1888
this short story sees a time traveler
creating a loop like what we get here
I'll talk about this all more in just a
bit but now just a quick word from our
sponsors now this video is sponsored by
Dungeon Hunter 6 this is the latest
addition to the Dungeon Hunter franchise
after a long line of releases since
since the game took the World by storm
in 2009 the brand new highly anticipated
addition to the series is now here and I
have to say it was definitely worth the
wait Dungeon Hunter 6 is a free-to-play
arpg with a unique hero collector
feature and stunning fantasy style the
game playay features a fast-paced
hacking SL combat Style with various
builds and skills to utilize as you
fight big bosses the game is absolutely
free to play and all you have to do to
get it is go to the link in the
description or scan the QR code on
screen now what makes dungon 6 different
is that killing bosses isn't the end
every time you defeat one the game comes
in with its unique mechanism that lets
you loot ride fly them and also summon
up to three of them to become members of
your squad you can get them to follow
you everywhere perform combo skills and
even shape shift into them as you get
further into the game in order to
harness their powers there's over 100
bosses that are updated monthly so you
never run out of fun things to do with
them dungeon 106 also comes with
optimized graphics for smoother mobile
gameplay the 3D Graphics take
performance to the next level and give
you the best visual experience in combat
and mobile devices on top of this you
can play with your guild mates and
battle in realtime Guild Wars play
through a variety of skill tree options
and trade items via the auction system
download the game for free now on both
IOS and Android devices use my link in
the description below or scan the QR
code right now if you're viewing on PC
for that you'll also get a special
starter pack worth $50 by just using my
link that comes with 10 sub in Scrolls
one SSR Lieutenant the Demonic wolf and
also an accessory pack use your game
account to end of the launch Lucky Spin
event for free to win great prices like
an iPhone 15 Pro Max PS5 Apple watch and
more starting October 13th check out the
description for more details download
the game there or scan the QR code on
screen right now if you're viewing on PC
thanks now miss minutes ends up blending
in by transforming herself into a sort
of Steamboat willly style clock which
Disney of course built themselves up
from might also be a not to flash of
Studios which were the thing at the time
and that giant ghost clock definitely
feels in line with it we then see the
book being left which Victor opens up
and we can see that it's written by
oropos technically he's the guy who
should be in charge as he's the one that
came up with everything instead he's
just been shuffled off to the basement
where he's been given a thankless role
that involves fixing everything however
he's so important to K that he couldn't
even afford to wipe his memory as doing
this would lose all of his valuable
knowledge thus he's been put down there
to not interfere with others but I feel
like the season might be about him
coming out on top anyway from here we
jump at the temporal Loom where Obie
says without he who remains temporal I
don't know how much time do we have this
shows that they need him to be the one
who manages what's happening and they
have to bring him directly to the TVA
now all of the pruned branches have
started to grow back which is
overloading the loom and causing all
these issues this means that even the
time lines that were destroyed us
sprouting back up from the moment of
their Inception which could possibly
cause more returning characters in the
end this overload could destroy the TVA
and truly unleash an infinite strand of
multiverses so far when we've seen the
timeline there's only been a handful of
them springing off but this would lead
to a countless number being created this
would destroy the TVA and its creation
clearly rained in the branches and kept
them under control now shout outs to our
editor M for pting out this is a similar
control room to Chernobyl which itself
all dealt with a reactor overloading you
can also catch a clock up on the wall
which has several hands showing that
time doesn't really exist yet he says
and we're going to die which goes back
to this line from last week we going to
die oh hey nice to meet you we're all
going to die missed it in our last
breakdown as well but this was also uted
by
X5 if we stay here we're all going to
die I'd find it hilarious if this was
doing some foreshadowing and we ended
the entire series with everyone dead in
this timeline anyway we see Mobius and
Loki heading out which is when they
arrive in Chicago when they step out we
see the
number7 and last week we had the number
one 15a on the licensed play at the
premere these numbers they sure they
might seem arbitrary but they could also
be hinting to something else going on
the Living Tribunal appeared in strange
tales7 and 158 with his Arc being the
character's debut he's slowly been dted
throughout the MCU with his head first
appearing in Loki season 1 it then
popped up in Multiverse of Madness and
love and thunder which may show inching
towards him coming in now from here they
travel to 1893 which is an extremely
important event this is the world
Colombian exposition to celebrate 400
years since Christopher Columbus's
arrival the fair actually had the
assassination of the may happen at it
which could be hinting out what may come
for Victor now mbsm mentions HH Holmes
Edison and the White City Holmes was the
serial killer that was active during
1881 to 189 4 with lots of his attacks
happening around this event Edison is
Thomas Edison the world class plager
sorry inventor who came up with lots of
incredible discoveries came up with him
on his own now Edison somewhat acts as
an inspiration for Victor as he's
initially just using the loom to
generate power boiled down to it though
he can invent stuff he doesn't really
have a clue what he's doing as he just
discovered it instead of creating it
himself Edison was accused of stealing
ideas from the patent office as he appar
work there and every time a big idea
came in from an inventor he apparently
just ran off and took it I kind of feel
like Ora boros might be scorn by what's
happening with Victor as well and this
could be a sort of Revenge plot in order
to get K now when we look through
history there's been countless people
let steal the ideas of others and pass
them off as their own Bob Kane got
credited as being the soulle creator of
Batman when in reality it was mainly
Bill Finger work there's countless of
these examples lay throughout everything
and I feel like the SE season might kind
of be building off the back of that now
as we said mobious call at the White
City which our editor M pointed out was
due to there being no classical
architecture which led to these white
structures as they walk through the
streets you pay close attention you you
can also see a newspaper stand talking
about the Liberty Bell this is further
followed up by alad singam who brings it
up as well as the main story Liberty
Bell 4th of July ghost clock continues
the Midway now this was commissioned due
to the Kracken the other one that meant
it couldn't be wrong this one was
supposed to be used on July the 4th but
the Bell actually missed its deadline
and got finished up in August now they
grab a paper and on it we get some other
nods to the time with the World's Fair
Hotel being off to the side this was
actually it's it's pretty dark this
reference but this was actually HH
Holmes quote unquote Murder Castle which
he built a lure in unsuspecting victims
featuring a maze of hallways false
floors and trap doors it allowed the
killer to carry out his crimes sound
sound mysterious with a cold now there's
also a mention of Watkins which may be a
reference to John alfreth Watkins he was
the curator of the mechanical Technology
Museum and on his Wiki it say as he
visited the fair in Chicago the main
thing thereafter though is the ghost
clock of Miss minutes who we see
terrorizing the town folk later on in
the entry beside her we can also catch a
Sketcher of vona because back then
cameras weren't as readily available now
from here we get a little fade out with
a black circle closing in which was the
fashion at the time and then move across
to the Chinese village in theater this
was a real life location that I think
and I'm stressing think think might have
inspir the one on Hollywood Boulevard
now they grab some popcorn and wander
through the rows which is where they
come across a shrine to the gods of nose
mythology owning his style to look
exactly like Anthony Hopkins and those
sort of he looks sort of like Chris
Hemsworth it's kind of like the hello
video with lonel Rich you we it's a big
big massive head and to be fair love
I'll let you off cuz you're blind but
that do look any anything like Lon
Richie mate the is this now Loki is
an apparent and instead we get Boulder
the brave why they include Boulder was
even heard of him sure they have Bal the
brave now we're going to get into some
bragging territory but you might
remember that back when Multiverse of
Madness released we dropped the
exclusive exclusive exclusive story that
Daniel Craig had been cast as Baler the
brave in the movie unfortunately due to
co he was taken out the film with John
kosinski's read being dropped in instead
Craig was later about it and he said I'm
not sure how you're going to do with
this next one have you ever heard of the
character balder the
brave no there was a report Daniel that
you were going to be in Doctor Strange I
believe it wasn't
it don't you hide behind that mug
[Laughter]
Daniel I don't know what you're talking
about in theory would it be interesting
to be in a Marvel movie I I'd take any
job I'm good I just like the if the
hours are good I'd take any job I of
course it's like um sure absolutely yeah
definitely okay
yeah he's good he's too good for me damn
it um see yeah Daniel Craig was pretty
much bald at the brave originally but as
we know things going on with the will
got in the way now I would have to go
back and look at when this was shot but
potentially it might have been at the
time that Craig was still involved this
could have been a little not to him but
it works either way and it shows how
shoved out the family that Loki is Bal
the brave is a big character in the Thor
comics and Lo's being forgotten about so
this character we've not seen in live
action him being pushed to the front it
just adds an extra insult now across the
road they see a sign for timely
astounding temporal Marvels astounding
is a word that's been used to prefix
certain comic runs and Marvel as well
you're smart you can figure out the
Easter egg there on top of this we also
have a nod of the musician Ferdinand
Lang there's lots of German musical acts
which we even catch on stage when we go
inside to see Ren Slayer German beer is
being served too and we finally get the
scene that was used at the end of
quantum Mania now I have to say I didn't
really like the Betrayal Mages was
giving off here as it was him kind of
Hamming it up and I I was hoping we' get
something more intimidating to explain
why Loki looks so scared instead he's
just stuttering about jumping about and
to be honest it had me a bit like uh no
I know people who've seen episode 4 and
they said he gets better and to be fair
he does improve as the episode goes on
his hair is also clearly based on
Frederick Douglas so that they have
looked at the time to inspire what the
character looks like now Maes actually
wore something similar at the Oscars
with even the color being like what he
has here man's just waffling about
though trying to use time as clean
energy similar to how pin particles were
used in Quantum Mania he mentions ropes
of voltage which of course plays off the
thread and he too talks about Edison and
how his device is more powerful now he
also says he wants to power the entire
planet and we know that the loom was
enough to power all the TVA Mages then
busts out a famous quote because all
science is VI
until and this is also similar to
demonstrations that Tesla used to carry
out at expositions with the prestige
being where they played it out in live
action well it was live in real life but
you know you know what I'm saying now
Edison Goons ended up trying to downplay
Tesla's discoveries and those sort of
goons they also appear here too meeting
Rona the pair of starcross lovers with
them being destined to never actually be
together in the newly established origin
Kang killed her and she was then split
across time appearing at multiple points
reincarnated throughout history every
time Nathaniel managed to get close to
her she was either killed or she
betrayed him and this might explain why
he who remains abandoned her now Victor
does say that he prefers to work Al lot
and this clearly spells out what
happened with them I don't do Partners
excuse me he stayed in the castle at the
end of time all by himself even though
he could have ruled with raona in many
ways it's impossible for people like
this to share power which is something
that we saw with Sylvie I wouldn't be
surprised if we saw a similar situation
in which he cast roner out much like how
Sylvie did with Loki he could then wipe
her memory and that would lead into the
new TVA anyway he's a con man a snake
oil salesman who's great at commanding a
crowd and he who remains was of course
really good at holding your attention we
see as a little bidding war plays out
and he then gets given
$11,000 now the second guy jacked up the
price was actually in on the deal and
Victor drops some money on the bar for
him raona sees it all and begins to
question it even showing that she has a
doubts over him as we see this turns out
to be right as Kang is and will always
be a very shady character maybe not when
he's iron lad you're all right iron lad
in a Mor you you've been all right from
time to time but you can be a dick
anyway I also think the series kind of
talks about indoctrination and how
there's people who will still follow
Kang even after he's exposed the old
saying is that it's easier to scam
someone then convince them they've been
scammed and people will often fight to
keep those they idolized in place even
if it's revealed to be a lie you see it
all the time these days with online
personalities that get exposed and
people jump to their side even in the
face of evidence I think seeing Victor
Like This spells out Kang's entire
character with him basically being a
trickster just like Loki about Loki
showing actual growth Raz Victor is
going to remain the same old con man
he's also similar to killan an Iron Man
3 cuz he's a bit of a loser trying to
pitch his ideas both characters went on
to become extremely powerful and they
were sped on by their failur to become
something evil now ly has some tricks up
his sleeve too and we sees he transports
a goon outside and in the Hogs cage that
we saw earlier this idea of something
powerful being played off as magic is
too akin to The Prestige with people
buying that over what's really going on
now inside we hear as a machine explodes
and watches Ren slay and Mobius bump
into each other once more we also see
that he's made trousers that apparently
make you taller and leg lengthening
stuff that increases your height that's
been a scam that's been run for
centuries I love how we also have the
idea of timely meeting them for the
first time here when they're much
further down the road which is sort of
the reverse to how he later meets them
now he watches Victor runs towards an
ancient Egypt exhibition which could be
a nod to his variant ramut reaching here
but bear with me and we see his Victor
hides behind a pillar and Kang right K
he actually hid out during ancient
Egyptian times and he became a pharaoh
known as ramut The Fantastic Four ended
up traveling back there which is when
they ran into the villain and then
defeated him an Easter egg for ritad
actually popped up during moonnight and
it could be spotted on the back of a
thug's jacket I was expecting him to get
teased out more in moonight but alas
he's never got referenced again however
syby does have an ank earring and I'm
wondering if this is a further nod to
him or even something linking in with
moonnight moving on though the Egyptian
temple was actually an exhibition at the
World's Fair which is a really cool way
to tie history and with the characters
the pair managed to make it to the
ferris wheel and we can also see a sash
and a woman that's discussing the vote
this movement really picked up between
189 19 to 1919 with women finally
getting passed in Congress June 4th of
that last year at this point Sylvia
arrives and last week she promised to
kill he who remains he shows up again
his Varian what are you going to do kill
him this is brought up again in the
episode you asked me what I would do if
one of his variants turned up and I told
you then I'd kill him and she kind of
feels like Loki's indoctrinated now as
all he cares about is a TVA again I feel
he'd be the the perfect person to
replace he who remains as he's now
starting to see how important they are
unfortunately they're what's holding
everything in place and I think that ly
will see that it's better someone's hand
is on the wheel if there's someone that
you can trust I think it's kind of a
comment on government and how people
often become politicians in the hope
they can change things however they
inevitably end up doing the exact same
thing that's happened before because the
structures and people who Ascend only do
so by sticking to the rules the syby
class is he who remains is the most most
dangerous man that's ever lived and when
you look at it he pretty much is his
variance across the Multiverse caused a
giant war and also wiped out trillions
of lives by destroying timelines outside
we also see raona shutting down the idea
that she can work with mois again saying
there's no we anymore the pair saw
themselves as a team during season 1 but
she betrayed him like Sylvia did Loki
and then escaped through a doorway here
Loki once more protecting he remains
while Sylvie wants to kill him building
off the back of That season 1 finale
Selby blasts them back off the wheel but
this isn't as powerful as we saw last
week there we watched as the pair teamed
up explaining why it was way more
stronger way way more stronger great
grammar in the video now misman it
scares everyone off by turning into a
giant ghost which people are already
afraid of due to those newspaper reports
at Victor's home we also see some of his
inventions which include a refrigerated
chair guys made a lazy boy with a a
fridge in the bottom and Matt our editor
Matt yeah don't want to don't to slag
the guy off but he he was saying how
this shows the guy's got real talent he
made a refrigerated chair M mate what
what are you about now misit starts
getting jealous that they're getting
close to each other and as we see she's
down to become his girlfriend she starts
complimenting him and Victor calls her
pretty singular she says well thank you
you're pretty singular yourself at least
you will be and this is because he who
remains wipes out all his variants until
he's just he who remains n talks about
how a version of Victor created the TVA
and M minut Praises him for creating her
she says they rued together at the end
of time but I kind of wonder how the
timeline with her Works she was there at
the end with him in season one but
conscious why she was before this event
here so at some point this version's
going to have to be destroyed and then
Victor will create a new one that
follows him through time the
conversations interrupted by the guy
from before I could could just look up
his name couldn't I oh there right there
he is in the credits and we could see
that is's actually called Rober Baron
looking this up it was actually a
derogatory term for an industrialist
during the 19th century people EO call
this who were known for exploiting their
workers which this guy seems to be the
type to do now Victor says that they
need to head to his lab in Wisconsin
which is where the character was based
at in the comics chased outside L he
runs into the group where he blasts
Rober Baron back turns out Victor has a
little hiding spot and due to all the
cons he's pulled in the past he he'd
probably rely on something like this to
get out of of people's way we then get a
brilliant overhead shot and this takes
us to the SS Heron I couldn't find a
historical entry for this boat but it
may be a reference to Kate Heron the
director of season 1 let me know below
though if you know what it is like did
your grandfather work on it and
interesting story actually and I'm not
lying my Grandad was Irish yeah and his
dad actually worked on the Titanic my
Grandad yeah one day was real enough a
story about how his dad worked on the
Titanic and my grandma goes probably why
it's sunk
anyway we had a laugh and we cut to see
the new Trio in the boat now this is
what raona L get stitched in but it's
quite a romantic moment I love how Miss
minut is kind of a standing for the moon
and he shows off his designs like how
Kate showed Jack's drawings during the
movie Titanic hey speaking of Titanic my
my grand never mind now these include
bring sticks and raona admits to giving
him the book and we see the F the
jealousy with a M minutes flaring up she
says I brought it to you you brought it
to him the way the post man brings the
post and then we can see her switch
sides and sit closer to him whereas
beforehand she'd been happily smiling
away we now see her frowning because
she's taking her man now we get a
picture of oroborus in the back of the
book and I'm going to do your heading
but he we think he's the big bad of the
show and that takes us
[Music]
into the part of the video where we do
theories so oroborus is someone that
we've been suspecting has an ulterior
motive in the series
when it came to the TVA he pretty much
invented everything and as we know he
was the one who wrote the book on the
tech rather than being thank to
appreciate though he was shuffled off to
the basement which you have to ride
through two elevators just to get to
this was so that he could be kept out of
the way because he's the only one that
didn't get his memory wiped this is why
he remembered Mobius visiting him and so
on and if he was interacting with the
main group he'd probably end up spilling
the beans now if we look at the comics
there was a Kang Varian called Mr
Griffin who actually had the ability to
cause people to time slip he also said
he'd been awake for thousands of years
which is similar to how Obie refuses to
sleep on top of that man man had a green
tie and I wouldn't be surprised if this
was a big plan for him to take over and
Rule everything man's bringing a new
meaning to the term disgruntled employee
and we've seen how this has affected
other characters in the MCU now Mt was
the one who came up with that theory and
evidence and if you'd like to see a full
video breaking it down then check out
the one at the end anyway that's the end
of
the part of the video where we do
theories now Victor talks about the this
is most important Discovery I've made
yet a throughput multiplier which he
came up with himself this shows that he
does have some talent but he's very much
standing on the shoulders of giants kind
of looks like a miniature version of the
time sphere which too had folding Parts
in elements that shifted on it it could
also be the core from Quantum Mania and
I feel like we may learn how it connects
to other things this even may be the way
they fix it to Tim Li him next week and
this upgrade could be what brings it all
together even though he's a bum roner
starts to see the man he's going to
become but at the moment she only sees
the good as we know he's a ruthless
conqueror that wants to rule no matter
the cost and she says I have my hopes
for this partnership however he's never
going to view her as an equal and
letting go of her hand we see misman Pi
up because she knows Victor is going to
dump her and dump her he does leaving
her stranded in the sea where she has to
row R roll her out gently down after him
now at Victor's lab we see lots of
mannequins which could be building off
the back of what he did in the comics as
you mentioned timely was trying to make
Androids and he'd often use mannequins
as a basis for his work also in The
Archers holding up the doors we can see
circular pattern sitting inside of them
this reminded me a lot of the spirals in
the windows at the castle and I love how
this is already integrated into his life
Miz minut then starts to FLIR with him
and to to be honest I found this kind of
weird like it kind of took me out seeing
what that she wanted to become a person
and it seems like she's going on a sort
of a weird Pinocchio story we learn that
she was a simple AI that played chess
but in the end K gave her autonomy this
gave her Free Will and she wrote her own
program which from the sounds of it is
to become the guy's wife also shout outs
to Mt for pointing out that Miz minutes
might be based off the comic Kang's AI
which went by the name bright head briad
actually worked with renl after she took
over Kang's time Kingdom so misman it's
wanting to be a brid's head yeah it
makes a lot of sense now I think her
telling him this is another bootstrap
Paradox in which he'll eventually
discover this Ai and then make it her
the big hangup though is that he didn't
give her a real body but as we've seen
it's probably for the best man would
have betrayed her but with her being AI
he's still happy to keep her around as
the help he ends up shutting her down
and betraying her to which is when roner
ends up stepping forward carrying a
prototype time stick this actually looks
slight slightly similar to the
retroactive cannon that comes from the
comics this had the same function as the
sticks in the show with it wiping you
out of existence at this point she takes
charge and then Loki and Mobius bust in
she says she put the TVA above herself
and won't be lectured about losing her
way last season she went to find her
free will but she's clearly wanting to
become she who remains I'm the only one
who can bring stability to the TVA
because that's what I've been doing
thanklessly for eons at this point
Sylvie makes herself known by using the
blast and she stands with a sword over
Victor this is of course in line with
how she had hero Mains last season and I
feel that there's a deeper meaning to
this Victor says he hasn't done anything
yet and it's sort of playing on the the
old thought experiment of whether he
would go back in time and kill Hitler as
a baby we've often talked about with
Kang how you never know what you're
going to get and there will be both good
and bad versions of him I think the
performance really starts to come
together at this point and Sylvia
realizes she's kind of becoming like the
TVA rather than giving people chances
and choices and letting them be their
own people they're simply wiped out in
the end she spares him and sends him to
the TVA but she still has unfinished
business with Ren Slayer as we know she
was the one who took her in as a child
and caused her to live this constant
life of Torment Maus ends up leaving her
behind and Selby shoves her through a
door like she did to Loki she said that
she wanted a seat at the end of time and
sends her to the castle which is now
falling apart absolutely love this
reveal and we see the remains of he who
remains with him still in the spot where
he died this is actually a callback to
the comics in which his corpse was
discovered exactly like this around the
castle we can see several of the time
strands breaking off which started to
fracture at the end of season 1 raana
has kind of got a wish and she's been
dropped out at the place that she wanted
to reel from however be careful what you
wish for as it can easily lead to you
losing out now what this move does is
that it scorns the pair and makes them
realize that they should take the
positions themselves when you think
about it they've both been running the
TVA anyway so they've probably wonder
why they even need he who remains at all
I feel like replacing him is the
ultimate goal of the season with it
basically being a battle over who should
rule a TVA now miss minut knows
everything Victor will do as she's seen
it all and she's basically become this
spoiler clock and is now teasing what
will happen next time now what I feel is
going to go down is that Ren is going to
learn what happened with her and he who
remains the pair were clearly close at
some point due to the recording we heard
back in episode one for all time he very
much gave the idea that they'd work
together but as we know that wasn't the
case I feel like they may show what
really happened with them and how he
wiped their memory and banished her to
the TVA technically this was a younger
Ren Slayer so she'd learn about what
happened in the past to banish her they
might also show how he who remains took
r Ren as we know that she had a life out
there too Ren Slayer was taken from this
and then drafted into the TVA and we
might see how she had a happy life
somewhere out on the timeline maybe she
had a husband kids or something else
like a dog and he took her away from
that and then wiped her memory obviously
let me know your thoughts below but I
think that's one of the big things
that's going to get revealed there's
also the possibility that Ren Slayer
could be a Kang Varian as well and we
have seen with Sylvan Loki how he can
have a version that becomes gender
swapped perhaps Kang and ren Slayer were
the original Loki and Sylvie and this
might be why he cast her out because we
can see the problems that would be
caused this would be a big way to tie
things in with the season and her
wanting to be the leader also makes
sense from an ambition point of view
it's going to make you real
angry now as for my thoughts in this
episode I think it was another great
little entry that gave me some surprises
I was expecting timely to be a time
traveler from the the future due to the
quantum Mania po credit scene but they
gave me a surprise and I appreciate that
I do kind of feel the performance was a
bit weird and just when when actors
start pretending to stutter and stuff it
just it feels very put on to me I think
the portrayal got better when that was
dropped and you saw the more personal
side to him but yeah I didn't like it at
first Ren Slayer also really Shun in
this episode for me and I think that she
probably had the best St in it I'm
excited to see what happens next time
and at the moment I feel the series
could really go anywhere now this is the
part of the video where we talk about
some trailer shots for next time so if
you don't want to know then I highly
recommend you check out now thanks for
sticking with us and I'll see you on the
next one now in the teaser we actually
get a shot where we can see a little
soup model getting pushed along a
walkway at the end of this we can catch
Victor so I'm guessing that they're
going to try and fix the loom who knows
where this is going to go but we still
have the elevator scene coming at some
point I'm still standing strong that ly
prun them Sol but let me know below if
you have any other theories anyway that
wraps up the video I've had fun talking
about it my my throat snacked but uh
thanks for thanks for sitting with me
now please drop a like May if you've
made it at this point and if you want to
support the channel as a member of the
spoiler Society then please click the
join button you get early access to
videos every week and it goes such a
long way to helping us out if you want
to get some heavy spoilers merch we've
got our t-shirt line Lo just below the
video that will let you pick up all
kinds of tops like our lcky one house
the dragon stuff the time the soer stuff
and a lot more we drop new designs in
there all the time too so definitely
keep an eye out and you know I'd
appreciate if you got one I love you
mate now if you want something else to
watch we've got that OB video on screen
right now so definitely head over there
right after this but out the way thank
you for Sing sh the video I've been Paul
I'll see you next time you take care
peace